BRENT OGLE: I grew up only 30
minutes from Hillsdale College,
and we would go and watch
sporting events there.
[CHEERING]
The mid to late
'80s in Hillsdale
was a very good time
for the football team.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I knew I wanted to play football
at the collegiate level.
Hillsdale was gracious enough to
give me a scholarship to play,
and I played all
four years there.
Really, football,
for me, allowed
me to come out of my shell.
I was shy, quiet,
not very confident.
Football gave me
confidence, and it totally
changed the game for me.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
From a long way back, my
dad was a very hard worker.
He passed that along to me, and
then, the football background,
I think it all kind
of plays together
that I wasn't going to give up.
So then, fast forward
to my time at Welch.
They make packaging.
We're not talking a few.
They're doing millions a day.
An opportunity came up to
be a general manager, which
was the ultimate goal, run
a branch, run a facility.
At 27 years old, I come in to
a operation of about 45 people.
One guy, literally, his
nickname for me in the plant
was Beaver Cleaver just because
I was so young, just a baby.
That business was losing money.
They needed a spark.
And so I was going
to provide the spark.
First thing I did is I worked
alongside everyone there.
I learned their jobs.
I did the jobs.
I remember moving
out there, and I was
working endless hours a day.
Chicago has its stresses
just being in Chicago.
You can't get trucks
in and out of places.
Drive an hour and a
half in a traffic jam
to get to work to deal
with the stresses of work,
and then you go home, and you
drive another hour and a half.
You get home at 8:00.
You don't have time to have
dinner with your family.
And so I was missing out.
I was in the car, or I was at
work more than I was at home.
That culminated in
a lot of stress.
One time in particular where
the stress, it got to me,
and I almost blacked out.
I started to go out,
and I caught myself.
And I started thinking, is
it worth blacking out over?
We're in Walmart.
We come out.
We sit down, and I have an
emotional breakdown to my wife.
LINDSAY OGLE: We were in the
car together by ourselves
without the kids, and
I thought he was just
going to say
something, and we were
going to get out of the
car, and we were going
to continue on our errand.
And then I realized very
quickly that he was struggling.
BRENT OGLE: I'm bawling,
and I'm just so emotional.
And I said I just feel trapped.
LINDSAY OGLE: I knew
that work was stressful,
but I didn't realize
where he was emotionally.
BRENT OGLE: I just feel
I can't, I can't do this.
I was just talking to her,
and I just had to unload that.
And she had no idea.
I'd held it all inside.
LINDSAY OGLE: I
just thought, oh, my
gosh, how did we get
ourselves in this situation?
None of this is worth it.
BRENT OGLE: In my gut, it had
been stirring for about a year.
I wanted to have my
own business, something
that I could call my own,
something that I could build,
a legacy.
So I left Welch Packaging.
And our plan was one
year, in one year
to find a business to buy.
The business that I own is
a sporting goods company,
Blazer Athletic Equipment.
We make equipment for
high schools and colleges.
Our primary sport
is track and field.
My customers that
I deal with are
dealing with high school
sports, high school athletes,
and collegiate teams.
I get to talk sports with them
at trade shows and in meetings
and couldn't imagine
anything better.
I didn't realize when I
was there how important
and how great Hillsdale was,
and football gave me confidence.
In that aggressive arena,
hung up the cleats,
and I can't play anymore.
At 40, even if I tried, I'd
be sore for a couple weeks
or maybe hospitalized.
So it switch from a
football field to an office.
Life is full of hard things.
There's always adversity.
There's always problems
you're going to encounter.
That drives me to be
better myself, drives
me to make the company better.
That competitive nature is
what has given me the tools
professionally.
There is a set of rules,
but at the end of the day,
you're still trying to win.
And I love to wake
up and try to win.
[MUSIC PLAYING]